[موسيقى]
خيام تنصب من جديد مشهد يشبه بدايات
التغريبه السوريه
[موسيقى]
بعد ان اعتقدوا انهم استقروا في ملاجئهم
ان كانت مساكن او مخيمات هجرتهم الارض مره
اخرى
هنا ريف ادلب هي ذاتها الارض التي اهتزت
قبل اكثر من اسبوع تحت قاطينها
لتدمر ما بقي من منازل بكل قسوتها تستقبل
الذين نزحوا مرتين او ربما اكثر
بعضهم وصفوا الكارثه التي ضربتهم بالرعب
الذي يفوق الرعب الحرب
صار عمري 36 سنه اكلنا طيران وغزالي
وبرابيل وما خفنا مثل هالخوفي
بتاريخ حياتي صار ما ما شفت من اكبر من
هالرعبه هاي
هذه ارضيه قويه والله
علي وما حسيت غير تحت الدردين
الحمد لله
مساعدات شحيحه وطرقات مغلقه واجراءات
مطوله كلما تاخرت كلما زادت معاناته نازح
الزلزال ليكونوا هم الضحيه وهم فرق اغاثه
النفس في الوقت ذاته فانا احد المطوعين في
بلده كلا سمعنا في نداء استغاثه لاخواتنا
هون خيام صار هلا عن مروان من عشره ايام
الجراء الزلزالة لحدث والدمار اللي ساوى
بها البيوت
[موسيقى]
بعض من المنظمات المحليه تحاول بما تملك
من امكانيات بسيطه ان تمد يد العون سواء
في تامين الخيام والقليل من القوه البشريه
العامله او بمعونه بسيطه قامت منظمه
بانشاء واستجابه
المراكز في مناطق ارمناز ومعرض نصرين
وجنديرس بالاضافه الى الاتارب والتوامه
وحارم
نزوح او لجوء لعله قدر لا مهرب منه امام
شعب قضاء اخر عقد في التنقل واللجوء الى
اي مامن او ما ظنوا انه المامن الا ان
الارض نفسها لم تعد تحتمل معانتهم
وعمر العربيه